sí y soy consciente de que ya mortal
kombat se le hace un par de días llega
un poco tarde pero jamás es muy tarde
conmigo
[Música]
la onceava entrega de esta brutal saga
ya están las tiendas con ciertos cambios
y muchas innovaciones veamos cómo le fue
la más reciente entrega en mortal kombat
[Música]
mortal kombat 11 es más que sólo una
mejora en los gráficos a comparación de
sus anteriores entregas este juego tiene
muchísimas cosas que ofrecer comenzando
con su historia ciertamente la mayoría
de personas no compran un juego de pelea
porque tenga una historia compleja como
una película de christopher nolan a la
materia les importa un [ __ ] la
historia y sólo se concentran en las
mecánicas del juego el sistema de
combate y partir las joyas piernas a
quien sea que se atraviesen lo cual está
bien pero en estos últimos tiempos han
evolucionado tanto los juegos como
nosotros como consumidores porque ahora
queremos juegos que nos complazcan en
todos los sentidos en lo jugable en la
historia y en sus mecánicas y créeme que
mortal kombat no te va a decepcionar
claro está que no le estaré más
intrigante y emocionante el mundo pero
para un juego de pelea donde ciertamente
la última de tus preocupaciones es la
historia créeme que está bastante bien
presenta una historia interesante y una
duración bastante buena con alrededor de
unas 8 horas para pasarte este nuevo
título une con una plantilla de
personajes bastante buena contando con
25 luchadores entre los cuales tendremos
a caras conocidas de toda la saga pero
también tendremos a nuevos peleadores
como los once tríos colector guerras y
claro la villa en el juego crónica
siendo esta última lastimosamente no
jugado
suma de estos 25 los errores tendremos
que esperar para que salgan los dlcs
cómprate una vez nuevos de los cuales
sólo se confirma uno por ahora jackson
pero está claro que esta plantilla
apunta que ser bastante más
hablando los personajes con ellos
tendremos en esta entrega una libertad
asombrosa al poder personalizarlos a
nuestro gusto claro que la mayoría de
estas opciones son meramente estéticas
sí es verdad que podremos también elegir
y equipar con movimientos de nuestro
agrado al luchador que querramos puede
que no muchos les agrade esto por el
desbalance lo que puede causar pero para
liberar todos estos sólo se podrá hacer
en modos de juego offline y en partidas
en línea no clasificatorias ya que en
clasificatorias y torneos se obligará a
usar las variantes por defecto de cada
personaje para devolver el balance y ser
justos
por suerte para tu voz este juego viene
cargado de contenido
comenzando claro por la historia de toda
la vida los combates locales y el
contenido línea que es algo bastante
abundante con bastantes modos de juego
como las peleas individuales o incluso
humor rey de la colina pero algo que hay
que decir es que la infusión excelente
claro está que si tienes un internet de
[ __ ] que solo te carga imágenes de
miley los ponys no va a ser muy
eficiente pero si cuentas con lo
necesario los servidores son muy muy
buenos así que puedes pelear con toda
comunidad
aparte de eso tendremos la cripta un
modo juego que se ven incluyendo desde
el mortal kombat 9 que es un lugar donde
podrás explorar todos mapas y unos
objetos en este caso la isla de samson
donde podrás comprar y descubrieron más
contenido el juego como los fatalities y
objetos para personalizar tus luchadores
claro todo con la moneda del juego no
dinero real
como de costumbre tenemos los modos
marca de la casa las torres pero esta
vez tendremos distintas variaciones de
las torres tendremos las torres clásicas
que son las torres normales que son como
monarca en donde debes pasar por varios
enemigos hasta el jefe final pero la
novedad del juego son las torres del
tiempo que son torres que se irán
desbloqueando cada cierto tiempo y que
tendrán ciertos desafíos como luchas con
desventajas con proyectiles durante todo
el encuentro y mucho más en estas torres
podrán ser objetos consumibles para
ayudarte a superar los distintos retos
de cada torre
suma unas cinemáticas de gran calidad y
un salto gráfico impresionante con los
visuales más que geniales en la parte
jugable sí que el juego cambió bastante
comparado con el mortal kombat y us ya
que en esta entrega el sistema de
combate no es tan rápido y frenético
como el anterior es algo más lento y que
te obliga a planear tus movimientos
comenzando por el hecho de que ya no
puedes correr además de que los combos y
movimientos de los personajes son más
lentos pero contundentes además de lo
que llaman bloqueos perfectos que son
básicamente parrish es decir que si lo
que es el momento preciso ahora es una
ventana para un contraataque
otra novedad notable son las barras de
ataque especial que a diferencia de la
anterior entrega ya no es sólo una que
teníamos que distribuir para defendernos
y potenciar ataques sino que ahora
tenemos una hora para los ataques y una
para la defensa también otra novedad es
que estas barras se rellenan con el
tiempo a diferencia del juego anterior
donde se rellenaban dependiendo de qué
tan bien fueras peleando
así que esto nos obliga a pensar más y
no solo lanzarnos a votar tratadas como
locos
ya por último las diferencias más
notables son claramente los ataques de
rayos x que ya no están presentes como
tal en reemplazo de ellos tenemos los
fatal blogs que son ataques especiales
que los puede usar una vez tu salud haya
bajado al 30 por ciento además de que
algo que me ha gustado es que esto es
fatal blow sólo se pueden usar una vez
por combate no con el mortal kombat y es
que sólo tenéis que rellenar una barra
para poder usarlos cuantas veces
quisieras sino que ahora tendremos que
pensar el momento exacto para usar estos
ataques ya que una vez que los usemos ya
no podremos usarlos de nuevo lo cual me
parece una idea genial ya que es el
juego un poco más estratégico
el último añadido este sistema son los
cuasi blogs que son movimientos en los
cuales siguiendo ciertos requisitos
podemos realizar un ataque con un daño
enorme que aparte no recordará a los
rayos-x porque vienen acompañados de
unas animaciones mostrando el daño que
causa este y aparte de esto están los
movimientos que vamos de la saga los
fatalities que no han cambiado para nada
más además de ser más vistosos con los
nuevos gráficos y mucho más brutales y
divertidos he hecho un vídeo hace un par
de días mostrando todos los fatalities
por si quieres ver
como conclusión mortal kombat 11 es un
gran acierto es un juego más pausado y
estratégico pero igual de brutal
energético como siempre con una gran
plantilla y personajes muchos modos de
juego bastantes innovaciones y
muchísimos contenidos para disfrutar
estamos frente a un juego que les
recomiendo encarecidamente a todos está
claro que éste será el último mortal
kombat en mucho tiempo pero con los drs
y todo el contenido que tenemos es un
nuevo con el que con gusto pasaremos
nuestro tiempo brutal y emocionante como
siempre pero más allá de la violencia
mortal kombat 11 es un juego de pelea
asombroso que te inspira a seguir
jugando y mejorando este es los mejores
juegos de pelea en los últimos años y a
pesar de todo los problemas que ha
estado presentado últimamente es uno que
te aseguro no te decepcionará